if one u.s citizen was suddenly
discovered you know saying hey i really
want to get out and i'm stuck would this
trigger a or hands-on deck type thing to
get that person out whatever the date
again we expect there could be some uh
but i i don't i'm not going to get into
it further
so again the the goal of the biden
administration is to just obscure what
is happening in afghanistan long enough
for us to leave and then they hope that
you forget about everything that just
happened we've had some tens of
thousands of afghans who've been
evacuated we still have thousands of
americans on the ground in kabul which
raises the question why aren't those
americans the first ones out
i want the afghans out too and we made
promises to those people those people
spend 20 years fighting wars in cahoots
with the united states they put their
lives on the line for american interest
because yes we have interests in
afghanistan against terrorism which
we're now going to pretend we don't have
for the sake of a dumb talking point but
if you're going to evacuate people and
you're the american government the first
people you should be evacuating are
american citizens so where are they
why can't we get them out why weren't
they the first people out the reason the
pentagon has been spending days
obscuring how many people were americans
on those flights is because the number
is really low again a week ago we had 2
200 americans out today we have 4 000
americans out we've been flying 10 000
american ten thousand people out a day
twenty thousand people out a day why
aren't more americans out what are the
obstacles why isn't this administration
being honest with us
well gen zaki has one goal and one goal
only and that is to prevent people from
using the word stranded so once again
jen saki and peter ducey went over it
went again whether americans are in fact
stranded in kabul
what do you say to the american citizen
in kabul that uh fox spoke to this
morning her name is she's going by uh
fatima she says we are stranded at home
for four days three days we didn't hear
anything from anywhere and they're
saying to go to the airport but we're
not being given clear guidance our
emails are getting ignored say no
americans are stranded this is someone
in kabul who says i am stranded so is
there a better word for somebody who
can't leave the house to get to the
airport because
jake sullivan says isis is outside the
airport
i would welcome you providing their
phone number and we will reach out to
them today
oh we'll reach out to them and if you
give her their phone number then they'll
reach out you know that's and that's the
important thing right they're not
stranded because gen saki told peter
ducey
who is not a spokesperson or a lawyer
for this woman or this woman herself
that she is on call
well great jen i'm sure that person
finds that super comforting and very
very very helpful by the way jinsaki
also said that as everybody knows when
we say we have to be out by august 31st
that means civilian evacuations have to
end before august 31st because again we
have to get the military out too so here
is jen's hockey admitting as much
does that mean that the evacuations will
stop before the actual 31st so then
there is time to get the troops and
their machinery and weaponry out of
there
that would be correct yes that there
would need to be time to wind down the
presence i will note though that the
purpose of this statement is to provide
additional context of what the president
conveyed to the g7 which includes a
number of very key components as he
assesses day by day
[Music]
oh well you know he's testing it day by
day and if we know one thing is that joe
biden is definitely on top of the news
which is why he has failed to actually
be in concert with the news for weeks on
end and was lying to the american public
or was ignorant of what was actually
going on so if he's on top of it joe
biden is on top of it the same way that
your grandmother in a nursing home is on
top of the news
sure
okay
all right by the way jen's hockey also
admits there could be americans left in
afghanistan after august 31st this is
saying the quiet part out loud right
here
if one u.s citizen was suddenly
discovered you know saying hey i really
want to get out and i'm stuck who knows
where somewhere in afghanistan or in
kabul he's got any problem would this
trigger a
diplomatic military
or hands-on deck type thing to get that
person out whatever the date
our commitment continues to be to us
citizens if they want to leave we will
help get them out
again we expect there could be some uh
but i i don't i'm not going to get into
it further go ahead
she's not going to get into it further
there could be americans who are left in
afghanistan we expect there will be
americans left in afghanistan after
august 31st but then we'll be working
back channels to try and get them out
you know none of this had to happen none
of it
how delusional is all of this how much
do you trust this administration i mean
i don't trust this administration
further than i can throw it which is not
very far the taliban have said we are
not allowing people to get to the
airport right the taliban spokesperson
in fact came out and said we are not
going to allow afghans any longer to
exit the country they say quote change
your policy please don't encourage our
friends to leave don't encourage our
engineers our doctors our military we
need them we are not in favor of
allowing afghans to leave so the taliban
is closing the doors on afghans trying
to get out because they are either going
to conscript them into the taliban or
they're going to murder them
but the good news is gensake says well
you know we are still we expect the
taliban to let them leave here's
shenzhaki
we've seen over the past several of the
past nine days a rush of people attempt
to come to the airport we certainly
understand that but that also creates
security risk and one that we have great
concern about so to be clear individuals
who are eligible for special immigrant
visas or others who we are helping
facilitate their evacuation and their
departure we are in touch with them or
working to be in touch with them about
how and when to come to the airport as
well as american citizens as you all
know and we expect that uh they will be
able to reach the airport
oh we expect it they'll be well and it's
not like the taliban's in control of
security lady
which we all know so politico even
politicos like this is gaslighting
politico has an entire piece today
titled the definition of gaslighting as
chaos unfolds at kabul airport biden
team projects calm
i don't think the president's rhetoric
matches the conditions on the ground one
former state department official said
tens of thousands of afghans awaiting us
visas and thousands of american citizens
are still stuck in kabul unable to find
safe passage through frantic crowds
taliban checkpoints and afghan guards
stationed outside the airport gunfire
erupted outside of the northgate of
hamid karzai international airport on
monday killing a number of afghan
security forces american officials have
repeatedly had to close the gates for
extended periods leaving guards to turn
away even u.s passport holders
multiple sources point to deteriorating
conditions inside the airport including
lack of power and sanitation tension has
emerged between american troops on the
ground and state department officials
trying to extract u.s citizens and
afghan allies meanwhile the west wing is
looking increasingly disconnected from
reality as the biden white house strives
to project a sense of calm competence
even as the taliban tightens their grip
on afghanistan
if you look at what we're doing now and
taking evacuating thousands of people
every day it has been a tremendous piece
of work said defense secretary lloyd
austin on sunday
while the evacuation has significantly
ramped up in recent days says politico
the reality on the ground belies the
narrative the situation is under control
the scenes around kabul airport have
been marked by violence disorganization
bureaucratic infighting and delays
according to video and text exchanges
viewed by politico
the result is an administration that
appears increasingly out of touch as
reports from kabul continues to reflect
a chaotic evacuation i don't think the
president's rhetoric matches the
conditions on the ground says jenna ben
yehuda a 12-year veteran of the bush and
obama state department and president of
the truman center which is trying to
evacuate afghan allies
they keep saying this was inevitable
there was absolutely a way to avoid this
if that's not the definition of
gaslighting i don't know what is said
chris purdy project manager of veterans
for american ideals at human rights
first
in order to speed the evacuation effort
defense officials in recent days
proposed retaking bagram air base
using bagram as an additional location
for flights out of the country would
help ease the backlog at kabul but the
proposal was nixed because the white
house and some pentagon officials
worried it would require deploying a
large number of additional forces and
could spark a conflict with the taliban
it was discussed but was not a good
option said one senior defense official
bagram would have been an airborne
assault just a huge operation would have
looked like a re-invasion you can't look
like a re-invasion guys i mean we're
busy surrendering here i don't know what
you guys are doing but we're
surrendering around here and if if our
surrender gets in the way of americans
leaving successfully well you know
surrender was really important because
joe biden wanted to go to sleep at night
knowing he had surrendered in
afghanistan
and he goes to sleep at like 6 30 at
night so we had to get out of there
right quick
the pentagon has acknowledged conducting
only limited rescue operations within
the city to bring americans into the
airport
but officials are running up against
that august 31st deadline
and i i don't think i've seen it
characterized better than richard engel
of nbc news did last night on nbc news
here he was
this war used to be called operation
uh enduring freedom and it's turned out
not to be enduring and they're not
leaving behind a society that is free it
is only free according to what the
taliban says it will be free if the
taliban promises that it will be free so
uh you could also look at this as a
tremendously humiliating
moment of american humiliation
leaving
forced to leave on the taliban's clock
and with the taliban's good graces
[Music]
that is correct and that is joe biden's
decision there is no one else to blame
for this except the old man who says the
buck stops with him so the american
people have said the buck stops with him
now the question is going to be where we
go from here how many americans get left
behind how many afghans get left behind
and will the american people continue to
pressure the biden administration to do
the right thing and get people out or
are they just going to forget about it
the way that joe biden seems to think
you will maybe he's just projecting his
own short-term memory loss onto the
american people
the battle for the culture is heating up
we here at the daily wear are making
some big moves so be sure to like
subscribe ring that bell because you're
not going to want to miss a single
moment